this video is sponsored by Skillshare
the first 500 to use the link in the
description get two months free you the
brave daredevil you are open Google Maps
through your mouse into the air and land
here there are palm trees lots of
20-somethings talking into their air
pods and everywhere you look a familiar
logo Apple Amazon
Intel Yahoo Microsoft Google all within
a few blocks of each other where are you
your first guess might be San Jose may
be Palo Alto or Mountain View that is
unless you notice the lack of Tesla's or
smell of hummus or the title of this
video this is silicon Wadi a cluster of
cities in Israel with one of the highest
concentrations of tech companies and
startups on earth it's home to Waze Wix
SodaStream and fiber files more patents
per capita than all but four countries
and is ranked the fourth most start-up
friendly nation overall behind only
Canada the UK and the US the difference
is those countries aren't next door to
the Syrian civil war thirty members of
the UN still don't recognize the
existence of Israel including most of
its neighbors in fact any evidence of
traveling there on any Passport prevents
you from visiting eight of those
countries because of this Israeli
customs stamps not your passport but a
separate piece of paper but despite all
of this despite the constant threat of
terrorism despite being only slightly
bigger than Fiji and having just
two-and-a-half percent the population of
the u.s. is realty companies and
entrepreneurs in the world why as one of
the very important world leaders who
consult my channel for advice you want
to know how to start your very own
Silicon Valley well you're in luck the
recipe is actually quite simple
first buy some ping pong tables throw
down a couple of beanbags and within
minutes a cavalcade of silent drinking
SmartWatch wearing CS grads will
assemble at your door even better why
not build some apartments a grocery
store and while you're at it
Pharmacy then they'll never leave work
wife what just kidding mostly more than
a few countries and cities have tried
charming tech companies with tax breaks
grants free 21-foot cacti and other
totally normal things but almost as many
have failed on the other side of the
Arabian Peninsula Dubai built what it
calls free zones areas with special
incentives to attract certain types of
companies like biotech firms movie
studios and tech companies at first
glance Dubai internet City looks like a
great success and to some degree that's
true it convinced Microsoft Cisco IBM HP
and Canon to invest millions of dollars
in the middle of the desert at a time
when the future of Dubai was much more
uncertain but having beautiful buildings
with famous logos on them is not the
same as creating an environment of
innovation you'll find plenty of the
former in the Cayman Islands but it's
not exactly the first place that comes
to mind when you think cutting-edge
research
meanwhile Silicon Valley is despite its
very high cost of doing business in
other words tax breaks may bring
companies but not necessarily innovation
corporations come to Dubai largely for
its promise of no income or corporate
tax for 50 years but often only for
marketing support and sales while hiring
most of their engineers in the US India
and Israel so what do those countries
have that others don't there are three
basic ingredients to a successful tech
scene the first is talent one of the
best predictors of which is
unsurprisingly education in the words of
Scott Galloway find the universities
that are gaining the most traction and
engineering or stem and you're going to
find an ecosystem that can produce a
unicorn basically put a bunch of smart
ambitious people in a small contained
space sprinkle in some idealism ideas
will collide and good things will happen
at the level of a nation universities
are about proximity and hey if you also
learn something along the way that's a
bonus which is great news for Israel one
of the most educated countries in the
world about 47% of those
over 25 have a college diploma the
Hebrew University of Jerusalem Tel Aviv
University in the Israel Institute of
Technology are all globally competitive
schools and because the country is just
so small and its population so highly
concentrated in just a few regions it
has the same fertile ground for
Entrepreneurship as a college campus at
a much larger scale about 92 percent of
Israelis live in urban areas almost
entirely in the northern half of the
country startups therefore are
surrounded by their customers business
partners and competitors the other
aspect of talent that's often overlooked
but just as important is demographics
not just how big a population is but
also what it's like for example it's
misleading to say only that Japan has a
hundred and twenty six million people
and Ethiopia ninety eight what those raw
numbers hide are their age and
background which can either act as a
free economic multiplier or a bleak and
costly undoing Japan's population may be
large but it takes an unfortunate shape
far too many old people for not enough
young unless millions of Japanese
suddenly change their mind and start
having children tomorrow
the Land of the Rising Sun will slowly
set as Africa grows into the next major
consumer market now Israel's growth is
not quite so dramatic but it is growing
which is more than you can say about the
future of most developed countries
including all of Europe the US Canada
Australia and China the problem is not
that Japan doesn't have working aged
people even as its population shrinks
there will long be millions and millions
of workers but they'll be busy caring
for their parents not inventing the next
big thing
Israel meanwhile has enough people to
care for the old and young with plenty
left over it also has some extra help
immigration the law of return allows any
Jew their spouse children grandchildren
and even their non-jewish spouse to come
to Israel and receive citizenship there
are even scholarships to cover your
expenses while you learn Hebrew the
result of all this is that there are one
hundred and
scientists technicians and engineers for
every 10,000 Israeli employees compared
to just 85 in the US the second much
simpler ingredient is capital starting a
business is expensive and someone needs
to write the checks the good news is
that the only thing Silicon Valley hates
more than affordable housing is missing
out
investors pour money into companies
whose only skill is improving the rate
at which they can flush hundred-dollar
bills down the toilet simply because
they don't want the feeling of having
lost an opportunity at a soft Bank once
word gets out that somewhere like Israel
is good at producing high-value startups
finding investors became exponentially
easier the more checks are written the
more venture capital firms pay attention
Israel's government got the ball rolling
in the 90s with big incentives for
anyone willing to come invest in the
country today 4.5 percent of its total
GDP is spent on research and development
which is just barely less than first
place South Korea now producing lots of
smart young graduates and giving them
bundles of cash is cool and all unless
they take those skills and that capital
to California giving Americans the jobs
and tax dollars the third ingredient is
therefore a high standard of living
Israelis have to want to stay in the
country it's a fun fact for South Africa
that Elon Musk grew up there but not
much use because Tesla and SpaceX are
American companies and this is harder
than it sounds
on one hand entrepreneurs and employees
care about health care crime public
transit and so on but it's a balance
because as salaries rise companies are
less strong to the lower cost of hiring
an Israeli engineer currently $73,000
over say a Californian 114,000 salaries
are so high in the San Francisco Bay
Area for example that if you're feeling
particularly cheap you might just buy a
20 million dollar private jet to save
money so you can hire employees in less
expensive Houston and fly them over for
the workday Israel has to be attractive
enough for people but not so expensive
that businesses VOC elsewhere together
these three ingredients go a long way
towards making Israel one of the tech
capitals of the war
but there's also another harder to
measure but no less real factor to
consider culture if you graduate from
Stanford with a degree in computer
science on Friday there's a very real
chance you could walk into a Facebook or
Microsoft on Monday and start making a
hundred plus thousand dollars a year or
you could spend your days begging for
money with the possibility of losing a
lot only to end up back at square one
when the vast majority of new companies
fail starting one is a huge risk
especially considering how lucrative the
alternative it takes a certain kind of
personality that's willing to fail and
do so very publicly in many Asian
countries the culture of saving face
makes entrepreneurship unthinkable for
many the reputational damage of failure
is simply too great in Israel however a
spirit of hutzpah roughly audacity or
bravery has just the opposite effect the
author of the book start-up nation
writes somewhere along the way either at
home in school or in the army Israelis
learned that assertiveness is the norm
reticence something that risks your
being left behind Israel is one of a
handful of countries that requires long
military service for everyone three
years for men and two for women during
their service Israelis learn skills that
apply to the workplace make lifelong
friends and business partners and are
reminded that their country can't be
complacent ultimately Israel proves that
there is no single factor to economic
success it has high rates of education
lots of government investments and
especially considering its geography an
impressive standard of living but it
isn't ranked number one in any of those
categories instead a combination of all
these things along with factors like
American foreign aid allow the country
to prosper it also shows that top-down
government policies are only so
effective at encouraging
entrepreneurship countries can hand out
money left and right but innovation
occurs at the level of the individual
his or her ability to take risks start
new projects and learn new things if
that sounds like you let me recommend
these videos on Skillshare this one is
taught by Guy Kawasaki the guy
responsible for marketing
apples revolutionary 1984 Macintosh in
short bite-sized videos he answers
business questions like how to ask for
money from investors how to pitch your
idea and why you should network if you
already have a business idea in mind
there are also lots of specific lessons
the head of production at anchor for
example has this class on how to start a
podcast whatever you want to learn how
to draw take better photos make youtube
videos Skillshare probably has it better
yet for you it's free for two months
just be one of the first 500 people to
use the link in the description